- C'est le trac dans la cour
de cette école du centre-ville
d'Odessa.
Il y a des petits réticents...
(L'enfant soupire.)
... endormis.
Il y a des timides.
La complicité des
retrouvailles...
(conversation en ukrainien)Et lt
la cloche et les fanfares.
Car c'est la coutume en Ukraine
pour les enfants de célébrer
la rentrée vêtus de leurs
plus jolis vêtements,
bouquet de fleurs à la main.
inien)
Après deux ans de confinement
COVID, mais surtout six mois
de guerre terrifiante, franchir
les port'école
est à la fois une délivrance
et un geste de courage.
(en anglais)
D'ailleurs, la première activité
prévue ce matin, avant même
d'ouvrir un seul livre,
c'est d'amener les élèves dans
les sous-sols, où ils devront
courir chaque jour, quand les
sirènes annoncent une menace.
Aussi stressant que cela puisse
paraître, ces petits comptent
parmi les plus privilégiés
en Ukraiules
les écoles qui ont un abris
adéquat ont reçu le feu vert
du gouvernement pour accueillir
des élèves en personne.
Moins de 40 % des établissements
du pays ont passé le test.
À Odessa, c'est seulement 10 %,
c'est-à-dire 33 écoles.
C'est donc en ligne et
de la maison que des millions
de petits Ukrainiens ont repris
les cours aujourd'hui,
souvent dans des conditions
difficiles, car la guerre
a exacerbé le sort des familles
qui vivaient déjà dans
rité.
(rire d'enfant)
Chez les Smirnova, la rentrée
se fait sans paillettes,
ni ballon. Les parents
n'ont même pas les moyens
d'acheter un ordinateur usagé.
"Ce sera un cauchemar, dit
Yulia, parce que nous n'avons
aucun soutien informatique."
Les trois enfants vont
se partager ce petit téléphone
intelligent pour suivre
leurs cours à distance.
Yulia dit que le gouvernement
pas les aider
pour l'instant.
Mykola rêvait de revoir ses amis
et ses profs, mais il devranteru
installé dans leur modeste
salon, qui sert aussi de
chambre à coucher aux parents.
Il est studieux. Il dit qu'i
sera soldat quand il sera grand
pour défendre son pays.
Yulia aura tout fait pour
les protéger du stress qu'amène
la guerre, mais ils en paient
quand même le prix à leur façon.
Les autorités en ont mal
au ventre. Olena Boinevych,
qui est la chef du département
d'éducation d'Odessa,
dit qu'elle attend des nouve
et du soutien de l'UNICEF
pour équiper les enfants.
Et dit que l'agence se mobilise.
Car pour l'instant, la priorité,
c'est de construire des abris
antibombes.
Et c'est un véritable marath
(bruits de construction)
Ce lycée est un des trois
établissements scolaires
d'Odessa où les travaux
ont commencé.
Donc, là, vous êtes en train de
rénover, là?
(L'homme acquiesce.)che macabre,
qui dépasse l'entendement.
(soupir)
- On n'a jamais pensé à ça,
jamais.
Jamais.
C'est bien difficile de...
comprendre.
Les deux peuples voisins,
les deux peuples qui parlent
presque la même langue,
et comme ça...
is pour
adapter la ventilation et
l'électricité.
De toute façon, le
ont peur, dit le directeur.
- 99 % des parents de nos élèves
ont dit oui, "online".
- C'est l'anxiété qui l'emporte
au quotidien et se lit sur
les visages des parents,
ce sentiment d'impuissance,
mais ce besoin urgent
de protéger leur innocence.
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-Canada, Ode